what's going on reject nation i'm dos
cavazos and i'm your boy roshi we're
gonna watch squid game episode eight
today very excited oh it's kind of a
short one huh oh yeah that's a compact
to the comb before
before the storm obviously yeah it's
called front man wonder what it's about
today
by the way hit that like or dislike
button if you haven't enjoyed our video
please subscribe click the notification
bell to get notified when our reaction
to the finale is up and as always full
length watch as long as we sync up with
the time code over at our patreon page
cover a whole bunch of shows there at
the same tier you get the option for
reaction highlights and watch alongs
included lastly thank you to um proper
paper uh yep that's what i'm called
very nice highlights
[Music]
whenever i hear this song i will forever
think of squid game now
it'll always bring glorious memories
oh my god he made it wow
you better get promoted immediately
on your return
12 battery
oh
jesus oh god
he's gonna make it though he'll be fine
i would definitely climb the direction
where there are bushes in case he needs
to hide
was she hit somewhere different than
everyone else
the
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
damn my guy
that was a really well written scene
that was a terrific scene well written
man damn
[Music]
an actual meal
no jesus christ
jesus christ oh
it's not fair oh ow
[Music]
that is not fair man no
man like a lot of this isn't but
she won and she got crossed you know
goal post of fairness moves
explode
yeah
yes
oh my god
oh my god yes and everything what if
there's like government people involved
in this i mean at this point i would not
be a surprise rich politicians yeah
[Music]
there's got to be an epstein in there
somewhere
oh no you're not looking good
god damn it
god damn it it's sent tangled making me
fancy no
no how'd they catch up so fast oh he
keep taking pit stops
sentence
twist is this is the final game
they are also not as tired as he must be
here
probably has some bulletproof thing
on yeah what's that mask made of
[Music]
[Laughter]
i actually hope she wins i i do too
oh not bad
no way no
it can't be it can't be [ __ ] no no
no no
no no
is it oh yo
oh god it's name yeah yeah yeah don't
forget the actor's name sorry
oh it is him though
wow what a twist yeah
[Music]
no way
[Music]
damn what is that actor's name begins
with like a
a bee i think oh cam man it's really
bugging me he might be alive still he
could be he's gonna shut his shoulder
and he fell in the water he might be
alive no no one has a crazy twist yeah
[Music]
i don't put it in that direction
um
um
no he's pretending
don't trust them is there no calm before
the storm
it is a storm already so dead
plus i mean if there's still an actual
other game to come like you might need
someone to be able to lose it
oh he's he is asleep
[Music]
i don't think he could stoop to that
level man i just seen
no
i don't know where oh don't turn your
back though
okay
no don't leave
this
so worried he's gonna kill her while
she's
exactly what i was worried about
[Music]
man
you better win this game dude dude you
better kick the [ __ ] out of sangwoo
[Music]
what they gave them their knives because
they wanted one of them to kill just
wanted to come down to two yeah of
course
[Music]
was he storm shadow and gi joe
retaliation
huh
that's what i was thinking i could be
wrong
i know i know that guy's face though
yeah wow having trouble placing it what
if what a freaking episode holy crap
let's look this up really quick hey yeah
yeah yeah
that's what i was saying
with the bee yeah
yeah nice to see him again yeah all
right and also painful painful to see it
again too i think i said it earlier the
opposite of this episode that i wanted
her to win
this damn show just breaking my heart
i'm not even surprised
right well no i mean every turn they get
every chance they get to truly break
your heart they take it but i had a
feeling man as soon as he left her side
i was like that guillain's going to go
and kill her i made some noise yeah he's
gonna wake him up he would just do it
but i i think it's really fascinating
how they've drawn this picture so far of
how they went in and they they knew each
other only like that was the only other
person he knew his only friend and now
it's become his greatest enemy yeah in
this whole game and it's not just it
didn't come down to i have to kill my
one friend or i have to kill my friend
it's come he's literally become his
enemy and it's interesting watching
how
this game they both
it kind of makes you think of that old
metaphor of like
two brothers are born we both have the
same dad one's a drunk the dad's drunk
and one one brother ends up being a
drunk and he's like it's because my
father was drunk other brother ends up
saying
i don't drink because my father was a
drunk you know and these two play the
same games same experiences
yet they evolve completely different
by the end by the end you know i know
it's not 100 of the same thing because
they were two very different people
prior to entering this game but that's
why i thought like ending off with the
starting off with the debate that
they're having this argument
of like what landed each one of them
here in the game in the first place
showing that they're not exactly you
know one is not better than the other
despite the choices they made in their
lives prior to being here
and then to see who they've evolved into
it's really it's really fascinating
stuff it's really compelling drama and
uh it's heartbreaking as [ __ ]
and especially because yeah like in that
argument you see where they're both
coming from you see both points and it
again forces you to kind of go like
well what would i do what would you do
and i feel like a lot of us would
probably want to be the gihon in these
situations but it's fascinating to look
at because you're like well without uh
you know saying woo he probably wouldn't
have made it here at all like you know
and so it's fascinating yeah to look at
how yeah they've both grown in the
complete opposite direction over the
course of the entire game and and
yeah this was just such a
psychologically nasty episode because
yeah they pulled them in for their last
meal and then immediately leave them
with the knives and yeah like it's funny
because they talk all this stuff about
like this game is fair to the utmost and
i suppose that still falls within their
paradigm with the glass shard but still
it's like
on the other hand it feels so unfair and
so frustrating it's very unfair because
they she already won she ever won that
round yeah and it's like this
celebration explosion is the thing that
gets it gets her napped yeah i know
that's how i did you know but what is
not really you can't reason with jigsaw
it's it's a it's a facade that it's fair
yeah it's not as fair as it presents
itself to be of course
i mean even right down to the game and
last time like should we make things
more interesting let's turn off the
lights yeah you know when that wasn't
part of the original offset of what they
were doing but yeah i think the actor
who plays gihon in the after the play
saying woo both of them are are awesome
and i think it's like watching
sang woo devolve
and then gihon
evolve
into
uh someone who like stands up for
himself was willing to get right up
close and personal be intense be tough
and stand up for what he believes in as
opposed to being like overly complacent
and polite
or uh lashing out and just ridiculous
anger you know like or where he's
frightened easily
this guy is uh he's really evolved much
more it's it's it's the art you would
expect for him from what they set up at
the first episode but it's nice how it's
subtly been done showing through these
scenes they're not doing dialogue that
it's drawing attention to that evolution
but you see it taking place before you
even right down to like the relationship
that he forms with i don't know what's
your name said biok
i almost feel like that k gets silent in
there somewhere but inside bo is what
you're saying yeah i think okay but yeah
having that relationship with her and
you know he's talking about having a
daughter in some ways he ends up
there's never it ends it's not exactly
like father-daughter
bond but it does become something where
he does look after her and wants to take
care of her you know and he does feel
very much connected to her and you
really feel for that speech that he's
giving when he is saying like we should
uh team up together and i was buying it
honestly i wasn't buying it
until he ran away until guihon ran away
and then
that sounds like he's saying we was
gonna get in there you know yeah um yeah
but her her performance in this episode
and this whole show has been uh pretty
grand too and having that
i you just it gives you that hope but i
feel like this show has been such a good
job at taking your hope and crushing
your heart that
you know like one scenario my mind is
going i want the ending
where
gee hun gets to get out of here and he
does find her younger brother or gives
money them both yeah is able to give
money and provide and take care i want
that ending
at the same time i'm like this show
seems like it could completely destroy
it
yeah yeah what what are the well it
could and i think that's an interesting
thing too because at first it makes you
wonder what happened to uh june ho's
brother
with you know like he won the game he
escaped and then we find out here that
he's the front man and so i'm like what
happens i still have that mystery
looming of like what becomes of the
winners do you really get to walk out
with the money and he just decided to
stay here or is there some kind of weird
caveat of like if you just return to the
world with all this
random
probably unmarked money yeah you know
like you might have a whole other
problem on your hands and need to exist
in a completely different way and so
it's yeah like there's so many more
dreadful portents and i find it funny
that this was such a short episode
because it doesn't feel like it at all
like they're still really great at
thrusting you into just like the tension
of waiting in silence and really letting
your dread fill up the room and uh yeah
i love the kind of way that the game has
affected them both because in a way it's
like you it
as a you know again a thing that pitches
itself is like a fair opportunity
for people to win based solely on effort
and merit uh at the same time it's like
you've watched somebody give themselves
fully to that game in saying woo and
like completely lose their humanity to
it and then somebody kind of you know
interact with it in a way in kihun's way
where it's like you know through this
crazy learning experience he's learned
yeah to embrace the the things worth
holding on to in spite of the system
even if it means ultimately not
necessarily winning so to speak i
thought it was
psy bio or something i guess um i don't
i don't pronounce it sorry so but with
her
i loved too of and he was about to kill
or like at least take a shot at killing
saying woo how she still wanted to keep
who he is internally like intact yeah
because she she knew she wasn't gonna
live like she knew she was gonna die oh
yeah and so i thought it was great that
you know they didn't do that
it shows the evolution of their
relationship from where it started
and to where it ended up here how their
bond grew over the course of this game
and how she's pretty much holding out
faith in him to actually make it through
the final round and he still is the
underdog in the situation yeah for the
game like this but back to the brothers
though with the front man reveal that's
a gnarly reveal it does open up the
questions of the rules of the world and
already with
bayong hung lee is that's how you say it
he's storm shadow and gi joe retaliation
right definitely yeah yeah that's him
that was my introduction to that guy
yeah um
so yeah when uh when you his performance
too i think
it starts making more sense why
like okay that's why he doesn't kill him
on the island he does or at least he's
not instantly trying to kill him or
trying to like
bond there but i thought that final shot
was great where he is in the mirror and
he's seeing his brother haunted by this
because clearly this guy had won the
game before yeah he's had to go through
the trials and errors he puts these
people and at least leads the situation
on so many people have had like have had
to take lives a lot of times personal
connections too he's had to do all this
and then even he himself is haunted in
the last moment and you'd think like a
guy at this level prob
would probably be able to handle it but
no not even he can handle it yeah yeah
which i think makes it uh more
compelling and more human
for that revelation he's not just some
evil brother like he was trying to get
him out of there alive and we don't see
if the phone
goes through if if the um if everything
made it yeah we don't see they kept
cutting away and they sometimes said
like seven seconds on it a few seconds
yeah we don't know if it actually went
through but there were like five video
files he was sending yeah just to
confuse the hell out of everything
and he's at least called his notes
i feel like he did at one point or he
could or if they are able to find the
phone or you know it's it's the future
now you can access certain asp things
remotely or in encrypted clouds or
whatever but at least he called a
superior so they know something's up and
if he goes missing further you know
hopefully they'll have constant yeah
something
uh but yeah i i love that that too and
uh
yeah it's weird it's like it's such a
great visual back and forth because they
both both shot each other in the same
place and it tracks i'm curious to watch
it back because now i'm like okay the
minute he finds that badge he's gotta
know and then yeah like you said it
makes a lot more sense as to why he's
not necessarily out to just kill him on
the spot you know yeah and i think
normally with a show like this this
would just be calm before the storm it
would just be like the night before and
they're all having dialogue exchanges
and quiet somber moods yeah and then
here they just made this like a
straightforward pulse pounding episode
you know like it was intense it was just
a tight 30 minutes you couldn't even
enjoy the dinner yeah yeah
before i got messed up again
but i loved it thought it was a great
episode turned out and i can't wait for
the finale man we i can't not we're
already almost there we're almost there
a lot of you guys already finished this
a long time ago
got one more to go
you guys thank you so much for being
here subscribe keep a lookout for our
finale reaction and uh last but not
least let's do a
jay valente hey buddy how you doing
if you respond to this you'll make my
day i hope that you get it and i hope
that it brings a smile to your face and
uh
this is the john part of the shout out
if there's anybody i could see you know
out there on some kind of remote island
being involved in some kind of weird
game for some kind of obscure prize that
involves both wit and might and obscure
intellect
you'd be the guy to compete in that game
and i think you would pull it out with
cunning with know-how with clever
aspects of yourself people aren't even
expecting he rise to the occasion jan
and i that would also explain why we
just never hear from you so uh hope
you're doing well hope that you win and
if you do
increase that increase that pledge you
know you'll have more money than you'll
know what to do with
yeah
love you man i would have taken the
route of he did compete in the game and
won and now he's the front man and
that's why we haven't heard
[Music]